[Music]
- we will see you in 2016 the vehicle
upper from you Oh sassy turning up mara
people in mid lane he's gonna flash away
but the ignite will take him down for
the first blood over the [ __ ] oh I am
really happy is how my first business
going I didn't expect myself personally
to play taking that vacation will be
better for us I don't think it will get
again much from screaming charges in
sign us to see application before one of
the biggest tournaments of the year it
makes more sense
she likes doing that by the end of the
year and people who call faker papert's
it refused to believe that I'm in there
and started sneaking down left and right
like you guys got even imagine how this
feels like I just wanna be a human again
[Music]
Luca perks Perkovic was born in Zagreb
Croatia on September 30th 1998 and while
he developed a passion for eSports the
country wasn't exactly a hotbed for
competitive gaming
I always knew like let's say back inside
of my head I knew that I wanted to do it
and I wanted to be pro but in Croatia
it's like so like not meta or Nike no
one has done before so it's like I never
actually that crossed my mind seriously
right it's more like he was more like a
kind of a dream you know
but despite balancing a full schedule
into his teens with wrestling music
lessons school and of course League of
Legends perks manners to catch the PI of
teams at the professional level after
playing with smaller European teams
perks eventually landed on gamers too
and after two stints with that team he
helped him qualify for the 2016 spring
split of the EU LCS and though fans
watching that series might not have
known it perks was about to usher in a
new era for Europe game is - they lose
two in a row and they deep polish SK
gaming welcome to the League of Legends
Championship Series game is
we will see you in 2016 the roster g2
assembled for 2016 kept perks and hybrid
from the squad that earned them the spot
while kick-ass moved to the top line
joining the roster were Korean talents
trick and Emperor and though the team
clearly had some potential they will by
no means favourites heading into the
season I mean Fabian is really
performing good like what's he cannot do
the dorm you
but once they hit the rift opinions
changed fast can the exploding bug
mister tornado will take him down for
the first blood oportunity fall to
chachi he was just taking time though at
that point it allows g2 to take part our
now get an engagement respecting the
bottom line from reckless and knocks a
clue to be to theoretically they should
win kick misses trying to gauge the
flash bullets and the package comes
across looks at both in too reckless oh
they both go down I didn't expect the
team to be as good as we are right now I
did have hopes for a playoff spot but
right now I think we're even contesting
for more than just a playoff spot and
looking into a toe for position so I'm
extremely happy with how our
expectations were met and even already
exceeded the t1 15 and 3 in the spring
split finishing it out with a 7 game win
streak I am really happy with how my
first bit is going I didn't expect
myself personally to play mmm that good
I thought I would like maybe joke and
say just something I think while he
might have been a little unsung before
the tournament perks when both were
keyed the split and was voting to the
first hole protein definitely got my
back
Roubaix but super jump back
yeah turns and he keeps on just gets
away
g21 from a perennial Challenger team to
the top of the EU LCS the future had
never looked brighter for perks and for
Europe but the first real challenge at
the highest level was yet to come the
teams finish had earned them a spot
representing Europe at MSI but rather
than grind even harder to ensure a solid
performance g2 gave the player some time
off it decided that Koreans wanted to go
home some taking that vacation will be
maybe better for us but I don't think
they would get gain much from screaming
challenges anyways so yeah they screamed
only this two days in trying the moonlit
intense criticism after the team's
initial games went pretty poorly but and
there is no one left to stop this team
RNG royal never give up take the Nexus
turrets take the game and look so damn
strong here at MSI Shanghai and they
have yet another win where the game is
actually pretty close to the whole time
the team issued a statement about the
vacation but it quickly achieved meme
status g2 went to and nine winning only
their games against the Turkish wild
cards supermassive eSports and European
fans were less than thrilled weakest
thought over G - of course g2 taking a
vacation
before
one of the biggest tournaments of the
breathing it makes no sense I think it's
a joke that / later confirmed there had
also been some issues in the team before
the tournament but whether it was that
or the vacation Europe needed more from
one of the most dominant teams that had
seen in some time so it's definitely not
the same team but we've said that for
four days now five days they didn't show
up massive disappointment honestly
overall for Europe as a region it has
been and now they can go back and focus
on the summer's put of the EU LCS g2
wasted no time and changing Perkins
teammates in a video poking fun at the
g2 vacation meme the team announced the
huge additions of origins bot lane Sven
in mithy
[Music]
shortly after that announcement g2
revealed that expects would become the
team's starting top laner with new
firepower in the bot lane perks took
something of a backseat from his
previous role at the team's main carry
but perks was already showing that he
was adaptable a virtue that would later
paid dividends and the new look for g2
was enough to give them their second
domestic title I don't know if he can
make the feel like
[Applause]
and as the team developed a reputation
as europe's bad boys perks was also
becoming a fan favorite well there was a
kid in the ground that had a son verax
please give me a shirt and there were
some people screaming so I had a social
pressure to get my shirt hopefully I can
find my second shirt it's like there's
something on finalist if I don't find it
in Syria unlucky their trip to worlds
sealed it was time to see whether the
team could make up for their disastrous
MSI and unfortunately for European fans
they couldn't g2 exited the group stage
with a 1 and 5 record in a year where
h2k semi-final run made the region proud
g2 was once again a huge disappointment
supported us and we showed up so poorly
every game besides the last one and I
don't know what exactly happens but but
I think this is just make us stronger
for the longer run and won tournament it
just sucks but the narrative was set for
whatever reason g2 just couldn't perform
at international tournaments and perks
was forced to shoulder his share of the
blame I was just like really reminds
that I just good you know and then
Taylor into like telling myself but I'm
never gonna fail again and then it comes
like the point I start working hard and
I'm like on yourself on like 2016 g2
made no changes to their starting roster
for the 2017 season despite the rough
world's performance they've been good
enough to dominate domestically the new
to group format saw g2 go 12 and one in
the spring split topping their group but
the midlane in europe is always a place
where anything can happen and in spring
arrival two perks emerged
to play me fight yup but still it was
another domestic title for g2 and for
perks it was relief more than excitement
because winning domestically had become
expected it was international success
they had to achieve msi was purchased
chance at redemption both in the eyes of
his fans and across europe he said I
should ask you if you're better than
faker so so what are your thoughts on
this on the subject I liked something
that by the end of the year that people
look old faker baby perks there we go
there we go and at that tournament perks
got to really draw first blood
internationally a huge 3-1 victory over
China's w/e was the success that he
needed
[Music]
to prove to
and while they fell to SK Telecom t1 in
the finals they managed to take a game
and after picking up another win that
summer g2 hoped to finally make
something happen at Worlds but Europe
would have to keep waiting for G to gain
trip 27 and a half minutes in Samsung
Galaxy will lock down their first win as
they start crew stations what they can
do and cleaning up their week
[Applause]
and give up unlike no
jeju reads books get what get pennies at
the autocross finds a few seconds longer
the are you mad
surviving is expect that steps up make
quarterfinals
and with their chance of advancing
completely gone the team picked Yasuo
for perks these are just saw a big man
awesome
as the crowd rose to salute a player who
even in defeat had inspired fans across
the world let's go okay so nice in their
traps and we'll take the Nexus they lost
all the Indians and lost barons
everything to a defendant with such a
long time when they kept winning fights
and now at the end they get the Nexus
the Yasuo pick from perks he said it
would happen they lock it in here at the
group stage of worlds
they take the game 5217 g2 eSports over
1907
[Applause]
[Music]
that was the last time this version of
g2 would play together perks was the
only returning player in 2018 and this
new roster would rely on him both in
gaming out more than ever before joining
him were Wonder yang cose yearnin and
would heed but while the roster looks
strong on paper and perks statistically
had a strong split they were unable to
defeat the number one team fnatic it was
fnatic that took home the domestic
championship and caps who secured the
all-pro team honors for mid
[Applause]
but now
and by summer it became clear the 2018
was fanatics here g2 had to qualify for
worlds through the gauntlet and as the
third seed expectations for the team
were lower than ever and maybe that's
what perks needed because once g2
arrived it seemed like he was
unstoppable and in a quarterfinal
against one of the tournament's
favorites even though no one expected
him to win showed up in the mid lane for
g2 eSports s5 it up it's already key
turning it back around to flash movie
tell them what's coming down those
foreign chi-chi to win the fight the
middling should for baby
whoa there's the game yes
Chuy's portable fighters on the kill
will town but the face is cheering
screaming and crying the underdog
breathe breathe
spectators laugh damn Louis the Jeju
dynasty will be defined by taking down
orangey
eleven kills zero deaths four assists
with his back up against the wall in
Game five against Royal never give up
perks showed that he belonged among the
best mids in the world though g2 lost in
the semifinals to eventual winners
Invictus gaming there was another
European team who went even further
fnatic and fnatic star player who took
him the most player of the game Awards
at the tournament was about to go from
an adversary to a lie the news that caps
would join g2 and perks would swap 280
carry was a shock to the European scene
[Music]
and perks
now jokingly calling himself Umi on his
solo queue alter-ego proof that he could
dominate even in a second role it's not
really what it is or what it even means
already comes from but it's what he
represents and it presents the new age
new generation so to say of Portland now
I actually got it from the random name
generator in case you guys are wondering
g2 coasted to a 13 and 5 regular-season
finish and were undefeated in playoffs
in their final sweep against Origen they
played the fastest best of 5 in the
region's history with an average game
duration of under 25 minutes g2 were
back g2 were dominant and expectations
were higher than ever but was this
dominance real or just another European
illusion could perks in G to actually
defeat international competition or was
just another vacation waiting to have
champions
[Music]
it was real dominance and after the
rough group stage of MSI g2 took down
SKT three to two before destroying Team
Liquid in the fastest international best
of five ever they know doubled isn't
there that slow is there enough time
that you can eat for a limit but he's
gonna be knocked up and here comes a TVs
for everyone else they try to buy some
time before today gonna die yet again no
TV for doubled instead it's suede here
and the gameplay goes well the barrels
limit is no Shane he's gonna flash back
to safety
yes just yet if I could run away slowed
down now by dad five going to come in
shopping
super jeeps you and make it a third then
will not be something put for the
midlane there is no chance TL comes back
from this there are already
turret this is what peak League of
Legends
comes from Europe
world record g2 eSports 3-0 will win msi
2019
it was Europe's first MSI wind from a
historical perspective this is uncharted
territory in league of legends wolf
swamps have happened but never had a
role swapping player carry just as hard
as before they've entered the phase of
denial it refused to believe in the
middle there and started sneaking down
left and right but like he could just
see it from the from the first get-go
right so yeah I know I know he could see
the first get this one but more than
that Perks his approach to ad carry
actually changed the way that maybe
ATC's viewed the role he popularized
champions like yeah so into position and
even top Koreans admitted that lumion
was teaching them about League of
Legends ta can even do it again look
about for climbing teacher can people
attend again who educated him okay so on
what sample contains a I mean root core
wood Mundi ruins a Dharan parent I mean
I didn't ship you and they got tomatoes
to take it when she's telling people
about Nana kinder to go to take a tight
hor get uncontaminated room those who
got you now European fans could dare to
hope that perks was the player they had
been waiting for that g2 who rolled
through the 2019 summer split to finish
15 and 3 and whose complete roster was
literally the all protein that split was
the team that could bring home the
biggest prize in League of Legends after
some nail-biting series against fnatic
perks had a sixth domestic championship
and g2 were on their way to Worlds and
they got off to a great start time for
first in their group with Korean
powerhouse Griffin it's gonna do it GG
to finish absolute dominance pot nine
were able to fight back with YouTube
held onto the lead they'll close out the
game and they look for that match first
Grimpen at the end of the day see I'm
unable to play spoiler as g2 rolls on
they move to five and oh and are now one
game away from having the first six
oh and group stage ever for a European
team a lost hi breaker saw them come out
second but they took it in stride slain
Titan after Titan to the semi finals for
the MSI rematch vs. SKT the last of the
lck versus the last of the LDC give me
your final words for SKT next week I
think Baker should be scared because
collapse is coming this is the greatest
history of legend take it down
the greatest team Europe has ever
produced px get ready
g2 is heading to Paris
[Applause]
perks was in the world's grand finals
but in the end their opponents from
China fun plus Phoenix held back the
tides of history BX are headed straight
for that Nexus and its only wonder and
perks left standing for the plus Phoenix
are looking to silence the haters and
stun the world with their style on to
the next and
[Music]
yeah I mean it's like really hard to be
famous enough in the video almost having
completion every single week practicing
at least 12 hours a day like you guys
can't even imagine how this feels like
guy it's gonna be human again
yeah
jeetu didn't make any roster changes
heading into 2020 but perks and caps did
shock the region one more time
well why do you wanna go Boston right
and you want to commit late well yeah I
mean I think I could yeah nothing I
could compare what Lane
okay well then wait I've actually this I
think we are what's the worst that can
happen and though caps appear to
struggle with the adjustment perks
looked as good as he ever did in the
Midland yeah this is parks is gonna get
knocked back so I've a dog he's hoping
for something but the dash back through
comes in and perks gonna finish this one
out but does get the flash I mean it's
big said that his team play right there
from g2 eSports and in the first ever
online finals he became the only player
in Europe to win seven domestic titles
g3 and g2 are looking to die reckless on
the fountain g2 are inevitable g2 are
inescapable Europe g2 are your spring
split champions as they take down the
Nexus and claim Indian their seventh
title matching the record set by fnatic
seven titles for g2 but whatever happens
this year whether G to win another title
in the summer or making history at
Worlds it almost doesn't matter perks
has already brought Europe to its
highest point yet he did it as a player
who wasn't even sure they wanted to play
professionally but who understood the he
had the potential to show an entire
region but it could achieve as perks
rose Europe phoned and in a new era when
Korea isn't invincible
where some of the world's best players
had shoulder to shoulder and where a
breakthrough player from an unlikely
country to find what it means to be
exceptional history will remember
perks
[Music]
it's up hey man how's it going
alright just wrapping up this edit
that's great that's great
let's talk indeed you to add a line to
it why the perks and caps are switching
back again it's uh Friday for the
deadline great job